when I toss Montreal revealed its thief
reboot it was kind of hard not to notice
that it looked like Arkane Studios own
stealth action game dishonored but it's
no coincidence these two games share a
complex overlapping history both are
inspired by the same source the original
thief games and while some of dishonours
developers actually worked on the thief
games back in the day idles Montreal's
reboot is the one that's branded with
the official thief's name the result is
that thief and dishonored are trying to
accomplish very similar things but which
one of them doesn't best let's look at
four high level goals and see which game
comes out on top first up the creation
of an authentic world the city of thief
and dishonored dunwall are both inspired
by Victorian era London thief takes this
inspiration more literally presenting
cramped streets smoky alleyways and
grand cathedrals dishonored goes further
into the fantastical with strange
security devices and mechanical
contraptions clinging to its
architecture yet it's dishonored city
that feels more authentic its large
atmospheric levels are rendered with a
consistent and interesting art style
instilling dunwall with a strong sense
of place thief looks great but it's at
the expense of an ability to render
large levels it's impossible to create a
sense of place when your game is
assaulting players with constant load
screens looks on everything and it's
clear that the city of thief is a poorly
constructed one advantage Dishonored
next offering creative choices to the
player both games offer a certain range
of play styles on the stealth action
spectrum while thief is more focused on
stealth and asano Idols Montreal did
want to give players more options than
the previous games
unfortunately exploring those options
doesn't feel creative the bits of
thief's levels that you can interact
with like flammable oil puddles or
anchors for your rope arrows a clearly
hand placed by designers you never
really feel like you're designing your
own solution just following someone
else's one it's easier for Dishonored to
make players feel creative because it
supports a wider range of abilities on
that stealth action spectrum and you
have supernatural powers but even the
basic first-person move set allows you
to engineer clever routes to your
objectives it's more organic inventive
and more satisfying advance
Dishonored now let's talk about the
cities themselves and how they descend
into chaos over time both the city of
thief and Dishonored city of dunwall are
beset by plagues tyranny and dark forces
behind the curtain if you kill a lot of
people in Dishonored you're going to
make things worse for the city you'll
start seeing more swarms of plague rats
and sickly citizens continuing with this
violent approach completely changes the
tone of the finale with a dark
apocalyptic atmosphere and little sense
of hope that dunwall can ever recover
it's a subtle clever evolution over the
entire course of designs playtime
thieves plot implies its own city's
hardships will manifest in a more
immediate manner but downtrodden poorer
sick of working for the man and they
eventually spark a violent uprising
against the city's elite ruling class
the idea was to show that with gradual
changes to thief's hub world over repeat
visits but there are so few characters
in each area that it doesn't feel like
the city is wracked with civil unrest it
feels more like you're going for a nice
moonlit walk advantage dishonored last
but not least let's talk about the
first-person immersion thief in
dishonored are both immersive
simulations a sub-genre spawned by
Looking Glass Studios that continues
into other games like the Bioshock
series these immersive Sims place great
importance on creating a strong sense of
self in the way that you inhabit the
body of a protagonist in first-person
thief goes for complete body awareness
Garrett's hands are on screen at all
times and animate with every single
interaction with the game world but the
need to ensure that everything animates
correctly results in a stilted and
clunky first-person experience where
control is regularly taken away from you
and your ability to climb over even
small things is inconsistent at best
dishonored doesn't animate everything
but it also never takes control away
from the player you're free to jump and
climb wherever you like though it's not
as realistic as theif it's far more
consistent which means you can immerse
yourself in what is possible with your
moveset as opposed to figuring out what
isn't possible in theif do we even need
to say it all right
advantage Dishonored so although thief
and dishonored offer slightly different
power fantasies they still strive to
create immersive first-person
experiences in authentic worlds whilst
offering creative choice through the use
of their systems and tools
but it's dishonor that accomplishes
these goals with far greater confidence
in itself and in its players ultimately
proving that having the thief's name
doesn't necessarily make for a great
thief game the victor Dishonored